il est grand temps de refaire le logo de
la chaîne oui parce que le logo actuel
est celui qui est lié à la série odyssée
sauvage j'aime tant ce logo mais il
correspond plus vraiment à ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur la chaîne et donc
pour ce faire direction un site en ligne
qui met à disposition
bah quantité de graphistes et de
créateurs qui s'appelle fiber et fiber
sponsorise aujourd'hui la vidéo donc
écouter c'est parti voilà à quoi ça
ressemble fiber vous pouvez si cherchez
bas tout ce qui vous intéresse vidéo
animation j'ai un peu flashé sur le
travail de strawberry wish qui donc fait
des portraits de femmes avec des
pommettes des pommettes saillantes et
est un peu rouge allons-y qu'est ce
qu'ils proposent à nîmes était dieu
visionnent trois concepts je veux que ce
soit personnifié jeu ce soit un visage
jeu que ce soit très narcissique
je vous laisse ici et puis on se
retrouve plus tard voilà je vous
retrouve le 9 février je viens de
recevoir ma commande je vais découvrir
ça avec vous donc je suis très contente
du résultat elle a pris en considération
tout ce que je lui avais demandé c'est à
dire de garder un visage mais d'insérer
des éléments qui montrent mon métier à
savoir la caméra et une amphore pour
l'archéologie qu ou sympa ça c'était
jusqu'à présent et maintenant
merveilleux ben voila
voila je vous laisse découvrir cette
plateforme moi ça a été très simple à
utiliser je suis très contente du
résultat je remercie encore faveur de
m'avoir fait confiance je vous mets la
dans le petit un lien qui vous envoie
directement vers la catégorie que j'ai
consultés pour faire ce logo est vers le
créateur en question je vous mets dans
la barre d'information d'autres liens
qui me permettront est bien de découvrir
cette plate forme est là on enchaîne et
bien sûr le sur le sujet du jour qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas dénué de couleur
c'est le sujet du jour
rome le culte impérial cetc pour prend
quand même dans les dents les dans les
tons
[Musique]
alors quand on dit culte impérial à rome
on pense généralement à l'empereur
caligula qui faisait décoller la tête
des dieux sur les statuts pour faire
sculpter la sienne à la place c'est
vraiment arrivé mais bon c'est un cas
extrême on parle quand même d'un mec qui
a nommé son cheval sénateurs le reste du
temps le culte impérial sa relève quand
même plus de la stratégie politique que
de la mégalomanie
alors je sais il ya déjà pléthore de
vidéos sur la religion romaine les
mythes et les dieux romulus et rémus
tout ça tout ça alors on va s'épargner
les généralités aujourd'hui je voudrais
développer avec vous un aspect qu'on
connaît moins donc le culte impérial en
fait à partir des dernières décennies
avant jésus-christ avec la fin du régime
républicain les empereurs sont
progressivement adoré comme des dieux
ils ont leur propre temple leur propre
clergé ont leurs adresses des prières
ont sacrifié en leur honneur etc etc et
ce culte impérial restent victimes de
préjugés tenaces notre amicale et du lan
n'y est pas totalement étranger
d'ailleurs ajouter à la vieille religion
romaine pragmatique et tolérante on
considère souvent qu'il aurait changé en
culte obligatoire orchestrée par des
empereurs mégalomane il constituerait en
somme un tournant théocratique et
autoritaire on a même très souvent écrit
que le culte impérial était la raison
pour laquelle les romains ont persécuté
les chrétiens en bref il aurait
transformé les gentils romain qui
observer tranquillement le vol des
oiseaux sur le capital en affreux de
bourreau fanatisés en réalité vous vous
en doutez c'est la phrase de la chaîne
ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
l'historien john scheid nous rappelle
que la religion romaine est fondée sur
le rite n'exige aucune croyance
explicite est conforme à une doctrine
cette conception très libérale de la
religion qu'on pourrait résumer par donc
tu participes tu crois ce que tu veux
tant que tu participes tu crois ce que
tu veux c'est un alexandrin oui et bien
a permis une incroyable diversité des
pratiques religieuses en réalité il n'ya
pas une religion mais une multitude de
religion à rome puisque chaque localité
où chaque groupe social possède ces
divinités ces génies ses ancêtres
héroïque et son propre calendrier
liturgique il y à bien des cérémonies
qui réunissent un peu tout le monde mais
c'est culte public ne sont que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg dans la sphère
privée les pratiques peuvent prendre une
grande variété de formes sacrifice
libations offrant monétaire inscription
ou simple prière en fait on fait
vraiment comme on veut ajoutez à cela
que l'empiré romain par ses conquêtes à
englober des dizaines de peuples aux
traditions religieuses variés celte
germain punique égyptien das berbères
arabes grecs etc et vous obtenez une
infinité de croyances et de pratiques il
y à bien le système de l'interprétation
romana qui permet d'assimiler les dieux
étrangers où dieu romain par exemple
belle carte des carthaginois devient
hercule ou le look des celtes devient
mercure ça permet d'y voir un peu plus
clair mais ça reste un sacré bazar et il
ya un jeu de mots plusieurs niveaux de
lecture c'est donc là dedans que
débarque le culte impérial et allez
encore un de plus alors plutôt que d'y
voir de la confusion supplémentaire il
faut comprendre ça comme une tentative
audacieuse pour unifier les pratiques
religieuses bah oui parce qu en
superposant le culte de l'empereur à
toutes les autres divinités l'état roma
en fait cherché à réunir tous les
peuples conquis avec un culte commun
c'est une façon de leur donner un genre
de sentiment d'appartenance ouailles et
non mais c'est loin d'être con et ça
n'aime pas trop mal marché
[Musique]
les origines du culte impérial remonte à
jules césar alors bien qu'il n'ait pas
été vraiment empereur puisque ce titre
revient à son fils adoptif octave qui
règne sous le nom d'auguste césar grand
conquérant et vainqueur des guerres
civiles a été officiellement divinisé
celui qui disait descendre de la déesse
vénus a été élevé au rang de dieu par le
sénat romain moins de deux ans après son
assassinat c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'apothéose on lui prêtait publiquement
des qualités surnaturel de son vivant et
elles sont inscrites dans la loi après
sa main la divination d'un dirigeant est
un phénomène sans précédent à rome c'est
une reconnaissance exceptionnelle pour
un personnage exceptionnel puisque les
prétentions divine de césar de son
vivant ont été particulièrement mal vus
par l'aristocratie romaine et on s'en
doute un peu contribué à son assassinat
à son successeur auguste est plus
prudent il n'est pas question pour lui
de devenir un dieu vivant le talent
d'auguste c'est qu'il fait passer
innovation pour une continuité toute la
propagande impériale est centrée sur le
terme de restauration de la république
ou de la religion auguste fait
reconstruire les tempes et condamne les
dérives orientalisante de ses anciens
rivaux comme marc antoine bon le mec se
déguisant pharaons aussi pourtant c'est
bien auguste qui font des organismes
nouveaux cultes le culte impérial il
inaugure une tradition dans laquelle
l'empereur est un dieu en gestation il
est nimbé d'une aura divine qui ne se
réalisera qui après sa mort on ne rend
officiellement pas un culte à l'empereur
mais à son nous mène à son gay nous deux
éléments assez difficile à traduire des
éléments de sa puissance divine en
quelque sorte ça paraît bête mais c'est
une nuance qui a son importance à rome
en fait il faut toujours préservé la
fiction du respect de la tradition c'est
comme quand on august dit qu'il a
restauré la république alors qu'en fait
il a tous les pouvoirs entre ses mains
bah ça donne simplement l'impression
qu'il n'est pas un tyran et avec le
culte impérial c'est pareil ce n'est pas
à l'empereur que vous rendez un culte
mais à sa partie divine dieu vivant ou
presque quoi qu'il en soit l'empereur
devient le centre d'un véritable culte
d'état et cette qualité surnaturel se
diffuse même à l'ensemble de sa famille
la domus à augusta c'est visible par
exemple au moment des funérailles de
marcellus neveu d'auguste qui aurait dû
lui succéder l'ampera lui fait élever
une statue d'or qui le représente en
dieu manque de bol pour auguste ses deux
successeurs suivant mais rossi avant lui
caius et du sud césar les fils de son
ami agrippa qu'il avait adoptée morts
respectivement à 18 et 23 ans sont tous
les deux divinisé on connaît bien cet
épisode grâce à la maison carrée de
nîmes le temple bâti sur le forum de la
ville est inscrit en hommage aux deux
jeunes hommes l'inscription faite en
lettres de bronze a disparu mais elle a
pu être reconstituée grâce aux trous de
fixation qui laisse deviner
l'emplacement des lettres exactement
comme sur un autre temple du culte un
talent qui n'est pas très loin de lyon
et donc je vous propose de partir en
balade avec moi
on est à vienne pas en autriche comme
pourrait le laisser suggérer ma tenue ce
jour là mais bien en isère on est à une
vingtaine de kilomètres au sud de lyon
au bord du rhône viennent est connu pour
abriter un grand théâtre romain qui
accueille des concerts l'été mais aussi
pour un temple particulièrement bien
conservé ici c'est un temple élevé à
augusta social ads rome encore une fois
ce sont les trous des crampons qui ont
permis de restituer le texte qui devait
donner roma est à augusto kaisa readily
filho soit à rome est à césar auguste
fils du divin jules césar puisque le
temple est construite son vivant auguste
y est révéré en tant que fils du divin
jules césar pas en tant que dieu lui
même vous avez compris
mais le temple a ensuite accueilli une
deuxième dédicace après la mort
d'auguste sous le règne de l'empereur
claude en 42 les villes épouse d'auguste
également divinisé c'est l'occasion pour
les habitants deviennent de financer une
nouvelle inscription pour l'architecte
du temple cette fois-ci auguste et louis
sont vraiment des dieux et peut-être
même associé à apollon puisqu'on semble
lire apolloni sancto est divo à augusto
est divin à augusta ce qui signifierait
apollon vénérable et au divin auguste et
à la divine à augusta soit libye
bon bah j'espère que cette petite balade
à vienne vous a plu on connaît aussi à
vienne par les textes un culte municipal
dédié à germanicus l'héritier de tibère
décédé prématurément lui aussi
décidément donc en fait faut comprendre
que chaque localité en fait piocher dans
le réservoir de la famille impériale
pourrait créer un nouveau culte et
témoigner son attachement au pouvoir
[Musique]
alors évidemment se pose la question de
la sincérité des romains face au culte
impérial dans un siècle où les dieux
traditionnel passé déjà pour ringard la
divination d'un simple mortel a de quoi
tourner carrément ridicule ça qu'on a du
mal à se dire que les riches a instruit
qui faisait ériger des stèle en hommage
à la famille impériale sur l'espace
public croyait sincèrement à la divinité
de l'empereur on imagine qu'ils
voulaient obtenir quelque chose en
échange l'importance de la
reconnaissance un petit coup de pouce de
l'empereur pour accélérer une carrière
dans la fonction publique on en connaît
plusieurs un des cas de riches notables
de l' empire qui puisent dans leur
fortune pour témoigner leur piété et
akiba ça a plutôt réussi alors c'est le
cas d'un certain et est amené
epaminondas epaminondas
originaire d'accra ifa en as appelons le
françois s'il vous plaît de limoges
françois de limoges voilà donc qui
finance un voyage jusqu'à rome en 37
pour aller
féliciter le nouvel empereur caligula
bah oui c'est plus sympa que dans rain
travail de fruits pardon alors à son
retour en grèce et finance des jeux
toujours en l'honneur de l'empereur et
le fait associé occulte d'apollon dans
le temple de sa ville
bref le gars il en fait des tonnes et
c'est pas kelly lula mais un empereur
suivant néron qui le récompensera plus
tard pour sa fidélité avec la charge de
grands prêtres de la province d'arqués
postes de prestige emplois publics
salaires notes de frais arrêté place de
parking bingo
on le voit le culte un talent au delà
d'une pratique religieuse pas toujours
désintéressés c'est surtout l'occasion
d'à de faire une belle carrière ces
élites qui prennent sur l d'offrir des
sacrifices pour l'empereur ou
d'organiser des jeux ne cherche en fait
souvent
leur intérêt et sabha les emprunts le
savent très bien le système est
hypocrite alors les élites des provinces
sont des intermédiaires culturel
indispensable
ce sont des relais de la romanisation et
il est normal qu'elles en tirent un
avantage alors on facilite leur parcours
leur cursus honorum qui peut mener ses
hommes provinciaux et leurs descendants
à des fonctions plus hautes et pourquoi
pas jusqu'au sénat de rome même les
empereurs surtout les emprunts en fait
ne sont pas dupes de cette hypocrisie
l'empereur vespasien se sentant mourir
en l'an 79 aurait eu un ultime mot
d'esprit selon son biographe suez tonnes
il aurait dit malheur je crois que je
deviens dieu cette moquerie montre bien
tout le crédit quelques uns des vieux
romain comme vespasien à cette
divination c'est juste une farce pour le
petit peuple
[Musique]
justement le petit peuple un parfois le
petit peuple il y croit à l'empereur
divinisé enfin peut-être peut pas savoir
ce que pensent et les habitants de l'
empire mais parfois bas on retrouve ce
qu'il écrit on possède des inscriptions
dans les sanctuaires sous forme de
graffitis notamment qui sont des
témoignages individuels de prières
adressées à l'empereur et puisqu'elles
sont anonymes et pas sur la place
publique on peut pas accuser leurs
auteurs de faire les fayots alors c'est
le cas à combe de savoie en savoie donc
où des inscriptions à l'empereur ont été
gravées dans le temple du dieu local li
mais tous étant donné qu'il n'y avait
pas de temples dédiés à l'empereur à
proximité quelques habitants sont venus
à cet endroit priait l'empereur de les
aider c'est pas bête hein quand on y
pense ah oui si vos prière aux dieux
immortels ne sont pas exaucé priez
plutôt quelqu'un qui existe vraiment et
qui a tous les pouvoirs entre ses mains
a priori c'est plus efficace c'est le
pragmatisme romain poussé à l'extrême en
fait dans la partie orientale de lempire
les populations ont sans doute aussi cru
à la dignité de l'empereur la
divinisation ou l'héroïsation des
dirigeants était une pratique courante
pendant la période hellénistique les
siècles qui ont précédé la conquête
romaine en asie mineure et en égypte en
particulier le culte des dirigeants la
jdc le cid a fourni un précédent opus un
pâle romain qui en a simplement repris
les contours l'empereur y est souvent
adoré comme un dieu avant même sa mort
et sa divinisation officiel en fait on
le voit il ne faut pas considérer le
culte un talent comme un élément d'un
seul tenant il faut tenir compte des
particularités locales et des classes
sociales comme pour le reste des dieux
romains on ne prie pas l'empereur de la
même façon à lyon à carthage à corinthe
conçoit paysans ou sénateur c'est pour
cette raison que beaucoup d'historiens
parle de culte un thériault au pluriel
alors il nous reste une question à
aborder c'est celle des rapports entre
le culte impérial et christianisme on a
souvent dit que si les chrétiens avaient
été persécutés c'était parce qu'il ne
voulait pas rendre le culte de
l'empereur en réalité c'est pas vrai la
participation au culte impérial n'est
pas obligatoire les juifs en étaient
exemptés d'ailleurs les romains il avait
compris qu'il n'accepterait jamais de
faire un sacrifice à l'ampera ce qu'on
reproche aux chrétiens c'est en fait de
se retrancher du monde de ne pas
participer aux fêtes civique qui cimente
la vie collective on leur reproche aussi
leur origine sociale la plupart du temps
modeste et leur inculture confinant
souvent à la superstition en bref ils
rejettent les traditions ils font acte
de rébellion
le christianisme secte nouvelle et
rejetant tous les anciens dieux sert de
bouc émissaire lors des catastrophes
comme celle de l'incendié de rome en 64
la plupart du temps la raison de ces
pogroms antichrétiens n'est même pas
connu comme à lyon en 177 les chrétiens
restent par principe suspecté de
conspiration alors il ya des rumeurs
d'anthropophagie de crimes rituels ou de
débauche collective mais le culte
impérial n'a rien à voir là dedans c'est
pendant les procès intentés aux
chrétiens qu'on leur demande souvent de
faire un sacrifice à l'empereur et donc
s'il refuse au nom du dieu unique c'est
bien qu'ils sont chrétiens le culte
impérial ne sert qu'a confirmé à
posteriori qui sont des ennemis de rome
au troisième siècle la divination des
empereurs continue d'être voté par le
sénat caracalla reçoit par exemple
officiellement l'apothéose en 217 mais
cette reconnaissance religieuse est de
plus en plus vidée de sa substance pour
n'être bientôt plus qu'un instrument
politique les empereurs demande ou pas
l'apothéose pour légitimer ou
discréditer leurs prédécesseurs ils
s'inscrivent ainsi dans la continuité ou
en rupture selon l'air du temps cette
utilisation politique est renforcée par
l'extrême instabilité du pouvoir
impérial au troisième siècle et quand je
dis instabilité troisième siècle c'est
52 empereur en comptant les corps aignan
et les usurpateurs 52 alors que le
siècle d'avant avait connu en
comparaison seulement 5 empereur en 95
ans
52 donc avec une durée moyenne de règne
de 19 ans d adoption en bonne et due
forme par les prédécesseurs pour
entretenir la fiction familiale lettrage
ans adrien ou marc aurèle eudes avait de
quoi mériter leur vérification dans des
camps l'empereur est un obscur général
de province acclamé par ses troupes et
qu'il règne que trois mois et n'arrivent
parfois
jamais jusqu'à rome balleux divinisé
devient pratiquement absurde la profonde
crise politique du 3ème siècle avec ces
putschs et assassinats à répétition a dû
porter un coup assez dur au culte
impérial la fiction de l'empereur divin
devait être difficile à assumer quand le
pouvoir changer de main tous les quatre
matins d'autant qu'un modèle concurrent
dont on vient de parler le christianisme
fournissez au même moment une vision
plus stable avec un objectif à la clé un
retour du christ et le salut de notre
âme ça c'est un modèle c'est simple à
comprendre au début du ive siècle c'est
bien cette vision qui triomphent dans
l'empiré romain
l'autorisation de la religion chrétienne
par l'empereur constantin lui même
converti sonne le glas du culte
impériale l'empereur ne va même plus
faire semblant de prendre ses
prédécesseurs pour des dieux puisqu'il
crois intimement qu'il n'y en a qu'un
seul le dieu unique les derniers
lambeaux de culte impérial tombe au 4e
siècle et le pouvoir politique s'appuie
désormais sur ce nouveau discours
religieux celui de l'empereur au service
de dieu et du christ discours
particulièrement efficace puisqu'il a
fait recette pendant plus milan
et je vous propose qu'on s'arrête là
pour aujourd'hui ça fait déjà pas mal
d'infos sur ce sujet bien sûr si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner je réponds à
vos questions en commentaires également
je remercie lucapa cote à l'écriture je
remercie faveur pour avoir collaboré
avec la chaîne vous envoie ce jour merci
et je vous dis à la prochaine salut
et caligula il touchait aussi avec sa
soeur
quand même fait un exposé là dessus sur
des puits
mais c'était il ya dix ans il ya dix ans
[Musique]